boa tarde
é um prazer imenso estar num evento tão
especial um evento que celebra o
conhecimento e acima de tudo a nossa
capacidade de espalhar idéias são como
chama de uma vela
quando você acende uma luz e não para
outro idéias são como chamas quando eu
acendo uma vela a pagar outra acender a
luz do próximo ano a pagar me chama
acender a luz do próximo ela multiplica
a idéia faz com minha idéia se espalhe
então hoje que todos os bondes nesse
palco as idéias elas possam se espalhar
se transformar e se multiplicar
bem vindos ao texas opção carlos
a mágica marte que manipula a nossa
percepção da nossa percepção daquilo que
nós julgamos real
vamos fazer um exercício com todos vocês
eu quero que todos vocês só são cinco as
mãos e olham para mim e sorriu
agora vocês vão fazer exatamente o que
observa muito bem vão colocar as mãos
assim sorrir de novo colocar os dedos
para baixo e vão levantar uma das mãos
olhe para o lado que tem umas pessoas
que levantam esquerdo outra lesão à
direita eu quero que vocês leram
levantem a mão direita e coloque sobre a
esquerda e fechem os dedos
vocês vão ficar sem mais ou menos uma
semana aperta as mãos não só tem muito
importante que o seu dedão direito
tentar lado esquerdo
isso tá certo tendo agora só os
indicadores button uma vez fecha as mãos
e olham pra mim
se vocês não foram manipulados vocês vão
fazer isso com seu dedão
o segredo está no pulso só assim sem
dobrar o pulso
agora sim agora
agora sim agora sim agora achei até que
fosse você e faça isso
isso esse é o espírito eu vou escolher
uma pessoa da platéia para ajudar alguém
quer vir aqui eu vou jogar um objeto da
escola vai ser aleatória
vai parecer que é combinado pra gente
selecionou uma pessoa vai jogar um
objeto é isso mesmo que vai jogar
cuidado com a cabeça e deixei até vocês
para o papão joga a chave para uma moça
que traz aí meu deus moça você de preto
você de preto você mesmo você isso pelo
martelo balanga ele é só um martelo vem
aqui na frente você vai me ajudar mas ao
final são eles representando a ala
feminina da platéia vindo aí com um
martelo de espuma tudo bem qual é o seu
nome
marília galera falou para marília oi
marília maria fala 8 marília balão
martel de novo joguei lá dentro
não vamos precisar dele tem aqui um
macho de cartas
você gosta de cartas ok dá uma olhada
nas cartas examina ver que você acha são
só pratas cartas de baralho brincando
para examinar veja obrigada também
examina bem não quer um bom forró
olha lá são cartas todas diferentes
todas diferentes naipes diferentes
letras diferentes
existem várias maneiras de embaralhar
olha com extraordinário jogador de
pôquer
eles embalaram é assim
jogadores de troco
a minha tia fofo
eu vou ensinar a gente não lhe solicita
que ele só tinha uma mão ele perdeu
outra mão como ele era criança nome dele
era rené lavando ele me ensinou
embaralhar sem ainda podemos cortar ou
cortar ou cortar
as pessoas geralmente batem palma agora
há uma causa tão só em todas as casas
são todas diferentes vai pegar qualquer
um novo influenciar a escolha totalmente
livre
qual que é uma qual você quiser aqui -
chama a atenção dele brincando
veja que são todas diferentes que brian
aí pega o paraná só não procura os
coringas a gente tem que tirar os
curingas shopping 6 isso não deixar os
coringas de lado
tem mais algum ninguém só de barata aqui
nenhum coringa aí perfeito perfeito
cartas diferentes qualquer alma tanto
faz
essa aí você olha pra ela lembra dela
não só por esse lado e mostra pra esse
lado
eu não vou descobrir sua carta coloca
você se lembra dela é essa nós vamos
embaralhar as suas mãos assim isso eu
vou colocar esse baralho na sua mão e
esse baralho com uma das cartas vai
pegar fogo na sua mão
fica tranquila que já fiz três vezes
eu errei hoje vai dar certo pensa na sua
carta
primeiro você tem que mentalizar que eu
vou ler seu pensamento vai faltar na
carta mencionava feche os olhos além de
somente quem é joão carta foca na caixa
foco na carta eu tenho a impressão de
que foi uma dessas aqui foi uma dessas
foi uma dessas três aqui não então só
pode estar procurando foi uma dessas
três aqui não pode sair à procura
para mim foi uma dessas três aqui não
então só pode ter procura foi o sete não
foi uma dessas três não então só pode
sair vão trocar de gosta de novo
foi uma dessas três não então ela só
pode sair seja que não foi o sete
assistências é um presente para você
jogar
gaga a mágica é uma metáfora que ela nos
diz muitas coisas inclusive quantas
coisas às vezes estão na nossa cara ea
gente não consegue perceber
ora a mágica ela manipula nossa
percepção mas quando a gente vai no
teatro quando a gente assiste a um filme
a nossa percepção também é manipulada
porque nós somos nós somos transportados
pra outra realidade para outro universo
esse poder da mágica também eu tenho um
presente aqui do lado
quero mostrar para vocês é uma coisa
muito especial
olha que legal é um balão
não estamos aqui hoje num evento que
celebra o conhecimento e que celebra a
nossa capacidade também de compartilhar
idéias
esse balão aqui ele é uma representação
do que é o conhecimento e conhecimento
eu vou pedir que todos vocês façam o
seguinte pega o celular de vocês na mão
coloquem eles o celular na palma da mão
de vocês
eles não vão só quero que vocês assim da
lanterna e aponta a equipe do palco
porque conhecimento é luz conhecimento
em várias áreas
o conhecimento e faz parte física
o conhecimento
pode ser tirado de nós o conhecimento
está ligado
o mundo está ligado também
paulo freire tem uma frase que eu gosto
muito que é a educação ela não
transforma
ela muda pessoa pessoas transformam e
esse é o poder da mágica mas que por
meio da criatividade ela muda a nossa
pessoa
quando nos juntamos os pedaços
nós estamos falando da marcha de
compartilhar idéias a marca da união
mas você daqui hoje você sabe que esses
pedaços nunca foram cortados mas foi só
uma ilusão
e hoje você se você está bem você é um
agente
você é um agente de mudança
tchau